okay hey everyone it's Michael vosa and
this is the order flows market analysis
for June 12
2017 and today the big movers were the
tech stocks they fell for the second day
um after spreading to Europe and Asia
that un concerns that Tech STX have just
risen too far too quick now you know
people there A lot of stories that oh we
got another tech bubble coming but uh
I'm not convinced with that but anyway
um in other news uh the British pound
retreated as Teresa may is still she's
basically fighting to survive her keep
her PM position um after the general
election and crude oil uh crude oil Rose
a bit so um there were some interesting
things in the NASDAQ NASDAQ was going to
be a bit hard to trade just because you
know the moves were so quick especially
on a range chart I'll show you the range
chart uh shortly but
um it was it was really it had a lot of
volatility in the market um and it was
kind of to be expected after all all the
stuff that was happening uh last week
so you know let's uh let's jump into it
here um but before I do got to go
through my brief disclaimer again this
presentation is for educational and
informational purposes only it should
not be considered a solicitation to buy
or sell a Futures Contract or make any
other type of investment decision
Futures Trading contains substantial
risk and is not for every investor an
investor could potentially lose all or
more than the initial investment risk
capital is money that could be lost Lo
without jeopardizing one's Financial
Security or lifestyle only risk Capital
should be used for trading only those
with sufficient risk Capital should
consider trading past performance is not
necessarily indicative of future results
now again it's uh it's going to be
another interesting week I think on on
the news front
um we do have uh sessions stff sessions
supposed to testify before the Senate on
Tuesday um later this week on Wednesday
well this week you're going to you know
I'm in Asia right now and Monday was a
public holiday so today sort of feels
like you know Tuesday feels like Monday
to me
um but um you got a lot of central banks
you got Japan Switzerland and Britain uh
policy decisions this week you have the
fed this week as well and you know it's
June right and they're they're talking
about a raise in June so you know if
it's going to happen this this is the
meeting it's going to happen at um again
you know this whole GIF sessions
testimony you know following the uh
James Comey testimony it just makes it
really it it's got my interest not from
a trading standpoint but just from a a
purely entertainment
standpoint I mean it's just getting out
of hand like you know just get on you
know let the president get on with what
he's doing um S&P though you know was
kind of muted like I said you know tech
stocks were down um you know it was down
about 2 and a half% on Friday they were
down about just over half a percent
today but you know Apple was the big uh
big loser Down 2 and 1
12% so um you know anyway uh we'll start
with uh I'll start with NASDAQ really
quick um just because you know that
that's on everybody's uh mind right now
um again I I don't think we're in a
bubble there's even some Joker from JP
Morgan uh my ex uh my ex- bank talking
about uh you know this is just a pause
and you know we we can continue but um
yeah you're session it was kind of quiet
there there was some decent you know the
the way it was moving during European
session was you know how it would
normally move during the US session but
once Cash open it just went Bonkers um
you know so just you know going back to
we had this low
here
um's go back a bit here because there
was some interesting things here um this
was about 3: in the morning Chicago
time at this 5710 level big support big
support here in the market th000 Lots
here boom we get through that and once
we get through that flood Gat just open
up um 5710
1,20 right here okay was that 10 or 10
and a half I can't remember now 5710 and
yeah we got through that boom big big
support you when a thousand Lots can't
support the market in the NASDAQ
especially at 3: in the morning you
better watch out okay I mean it doesn't
take a rocket scientist to figure that
out so so what we do we sold off uh
sharply quickly 312 312 314 so from you
know 312 over the next 5 minutes we went
from you know
5710 you know all the way down to 56 you
know 5694 so we had a 15 full point move
in the NASDAQ um you know within 5
minutes and we still weren't done we
still went lower lower lower lower lower
lower lower you know um we hit this low
here at 345
5680 got a single print Divergence we do
bounce up get up here this bar point of
control right at the top you do have a
bearish ratio as well next bar Delta
scalper giving you a sell signal we sell
off bounce up a little bit at this point
you know we're still moving pretty quick
but not you know like in fast Market
mode um I see a lot of zero prints here
which indicates me there's not
necessarily a lot of liquidity at this
point but I mean you know it's it's
Europe session um and it's moving pretty
good already
so you know watch watch as we get into
you know later um so you know you still
have the I said you got your Delta scalp
is short you got your point of control
right up on the top there um you know is
it's
bearish um come down here we get to this
low here a new low
5678 no Divergence no ratio we do rally
though off up off that low um you know
quite nicely we got all the way back up
to uh you know close to 5700 then we
bounce up again get above 5700 we still
have haven't gotten above 5710 where
that big volume was there um then you
get Delta scalper kicking off again and
again you sell off from the 5700 area um
you
know down to the uh you know
5695 5694 area start rallying again um
this time it's only 4 in the morning and
and look at this we've had a a terrific
range
already it's just moving quite nicely
Delta scalper another buy here around
the 5705 level now we're back up to that
5710 area here
um okay and you know again I'm going to
be curious to see what we got up there
we have a dogee bar um pting control in
that bar right at the high you know I'd
be curious to see if there was going to
be some more selling coming in there I
mean before you had that buying right I
mean it was on the bid right 1,20 on the
bid um you know I'm just curious to see
what it was going to look like when we
got back up there if if um cuz you had
to had obviously you had a lot of
sellers at that point selling into that
bid but once that bid broke broke
through yeah I said you know the market
was just really looking for a bottom and
you know it you know had it found his
bottom yet at that point no you know it
kept going lower kept going lower um
again I I was kind of curious to see if
we get back up there if we're going to
see aggressive selling coming in there
not really you don't really see it you
got Delta scalper here kicking off
around 576 area get back all the way up
to the
1213 area Delta scoper giv a nice sell
here around you know in this bar we're
trading 5711 and then again another nice
quick sharp sell off from 57 um 11 down
below
5700 nothing on this low here you you
know it's a single print no Divergence
no ratio bounc back up a bit um anyway I
said it's it's moving quite nicely here
um you know another Delta scalper this
is already seven okay now now things now
it's really starting to move very quick
it would go quick pause go quick pause
here you got 56.90 you got you know
someone offering you know a th there
here you hit you got the point of
control right at the top 172 trade there
right got a buying inbalance there
you've got a ratio point of control
right at the
top to me this is very bearish I'm
looking for the market to sell off it
doesn't it comes right back up there's
still an offer there
5690 very solid offer it gets through
that you know that that's what scares me
um you know it just chewed right back up
through there and you know we just
rallied from there so I mean you got to
watch that but then it happened very qu
fast 721 this bar is still 721 721 722
you know so once we got past that it
just you know it it jumped a quick um
you know almost you know what is that
from 50 what would I say that level
was
5690 all the way up to
50 all the way up here to 5710 again um
Delta scalper on on a green bar though
I'm not interested in it now coming in
let's take a look once cash
opens let's get here to the cash now you
know again you know Delta scalper are
giving you a buy seconds before the cash
open I'm not sure I'd want to take it
especially with all the volatility in
the market but again you know if you
want to you can but you make sure you
got a stop in there cash opens and now
it's just bunkers time you know 8:30 you
know here where's 8:30 right here 8:30
56 98
roughly 25 seconds later you're trading
10 points lower you know that just gives
you an idea of how volatile this Market
is at this point um you know we're just
all over the place new lows 831
5678 so again you know it's just going
berserko um again do you have to trade
at this time no you don't right um you
should be able to notice how fast this
Market's moving if you're trading a
range based if you're trading a minute
based charts you know your charts just
all over the place but on a range based
chart you know it's put in new bars
every um few seconds which tells me that
hey you know there's a lot of volatility
in this market wait for things to settle
down um and do they not really um again
it's just all over the place
here a lot of volatility I mean you know
people got you know all sorts of
different perception on on what's the
Market's going to do you know here you
get a nice Delta scalper buy and it
fails on you within um 10 seconds it's
already going against you that's how
fast this Market is moving another Delta
scalper buy this one you know does go in
your favor but again 836 24 seconds 836
29 seconds is this bar 40 seconds is
here by the time you're getting in it's
giving you a Delta scalper uh sell and
again you know it sells off a bit but
it's you know it's a market that's
moving very fast and you better be very
quick if if you're trading
manually you know then Delta scalper buy
doesn't work out um we sell off Delta
scalper buy this time you know this one
again you got be quick 838 o 838 4
seconds 838 6 seconds 9 seconds so you
know if you're fast yeah you could catch
most of that move but if you're not you
know you're you're there sucking wind
and then next thing you know it's
trading against you so um you know
anyway I I don't want to go you know
there's a lot of you know signals this
morning on an eight range NASDAQ chart
normally on eight range NASDAQ chart you
know on on a market that's not like
today it's it's a lot calmer easier to
trade um but on this session it was uh a
bit all over the place anyway then the
next Market uh I'll talk about is crude
now crude was was very interesting um
this morning around uh 520 you hit this
area here
46 I think it was 13 or something 4615
rather and this is what a stop based it
stacked in Balance looks like here you
get up to this High boom you trigger
boom all zeros all the way up then you
come back in over the next bar and this
bar it really retraced almost the whole
bar here before going back up but this
is what it looks like when a stop gets
triggered it everything gets gets um I
mean the stop was here right before the
high but you know do I think this is a
sweep in the sense that a buyer came and
said hey buy me um you know 1,200
contracts no um to me this is what a
stop looks like and it just sort of
Builds on itself and then it comes back
in usually when a Trader comes in and
sweeps the entire book you know 10 cents
or whatever in in the crude it doesn't
retrace like this it just goes it keeps
going higher in this case it's a stop
buying buy byy byy you know it's all the
orders are being triggered it gets
filled buying stops immediately it comes
back in and then it could go back up or
it could go back down but this is what a
stop based um stacked imbalance looks
like you get all the zeros all the
imbalances and then a bit of a pullback
in the next bar you know as Traders are
trying to figure out you know what just
happened was that a stop being triggered
was that someone coming in sweeping the
book or what I mean it you but to me in
my based on my experience and my
experience on sweeping the book in the
crude um for for size when I used to
work at Cargill and JP Morgan that's
what it looks like okay I I know that
you know when I sweep the book in
certain markets um it doesn't pull back
you know I I us to do it regularly in
Cotton I would sweep it up 50 cents and
it would never retrace cuz I'd be bid
there usually when somebody sweeps the
market they're sitting on a bid here as
well so they buy a th000 say they got
2,000 to buy they sweep it up and it's
bid over at this level so there's no
chance for it to come back down okay
because again you know a Trader that's
sweeping the book they're looking at
their average price on the fill you know
they don't give a well oh I got 136
here 117 here 92 here they know okay
we're trading 4614 hey I could buy um a
th000 all the way up to
4624 okay and I I'll be bid there and I
know my average is going to be around
4672 I'll do it because you know what I
just got a position my average price
4672 and now I'm biding the market at
4622 you know that that's how they
think so anyway that's what a stack uh
stop induced uh stacked imbalance looks
like um so we get up to this high at 526
it's a uh Divergence no ratio no ratio
in the next bar even um I thought this
bar was kind of bullish it just came
right back on you made a new High um got
another failed imbalance here got a new
high up here no Divergence now it's
starting to get interesting here it's
coming off stacked
imbalance Market comes right back up
it's you know point of control on this
bar right near the low the Stacked
imbalance uh failed I to me it it failed
um because he spent all this time above
above the Stacked
imbalance and then um starts get
interesting here during the US
hours a nice uh Delta Scupper by here
around the 46 uh you know 38 area and we
we rally all the way up to you know the
60s actually get up to 71 in new high
start coming out here you get a stacked
inbalance just sort of go sideways comes
off in the next bar or two and just sort
of go sideways on you and then you get a
nice uh Delta scalper giving you a sell
here and you know it sells off nicely
you get some confirmation here nice
stacked inbalance coming in here um
followed by another stacked imbalance
and know down in here around the 4612
area so you know you're you're up here
at the 4650 area you got a Delta scalper
cell and it sells all the way down into
the the the teens um before you get
another stacked in uh Delta scalper
giving you a buy and it does pop up a
bit um my my chart sended strangely at
uh
120 and uh so that was the crude which
was interesting um next market I'll talk
about was was soybeans really quick I I
thought thought it was interesting I
know a lot of you guys don't give a
about soybeans but you know it's it's a
nice Market to trade um you know it's
not as volatile as some of these other I
mean it can be volatile I we had the
wasd report come out the other day and
beans were all over the place but um you
know it it's a market that you know if
you're a trading purist um order flows
doeses
follow um quite nicely so where am I
okay so you got this 9:00 you got stack
selling and bounc until a low now you
know I I don't like taking Stacks sell
and balances going into low yes the
market can go lower but it can also be a
limited move did go lower in the next
bar by a tick but then here you got the
Delta scalper giving you a nice buy
right off the low I love getting Delta
scalper buys off lows or Delta Scupper
sells off highs and here you got you
know right off your low is it is it a
10-cent move no but still it's a move
from 935 all the way up to the 939 area
and then you get a Delta scalper cell
off a swing a nice swing High here you
have this bar ratio bounds low so you
got some stopping volume up there you've
got point of control up here near the
top even on this move up you can see
you're seeing some selling coming in
here 524 193 232 even selling into these
bids 239 497 so you know you got
interested sellers up here okay point of
control right at the top stopping this
move capping it Delta scalper kicking in
telling you sellers are taking over now
and what do you do you start going
sideways sideways and then boom selling
comes in and you make new lows from you
know this this
938 area down into you know 931 where
you get again some nice volume even down
here right at 933 you got 1,600
contracts you get through
that down here it stops at 946 you know
the sellers just can't take it anymore
they capitulate I can't sell anymore I'm
done you know I sold I sold the out
of this even down here 8.98 they sold
1,600 and they're selling you know
they're selling more selling more but
there's still these buyers creeping in
here
um you know bidding down here at 931 at
almost 1,000 contracts and you sort of
bounce up a bit does come back down
tests it again gets through it by a few
ticks test it again in this next bar
here and then we close for the
day now the last market I'll talk about
today is um
bonds okay well I'll tell you what I
I'll throw in the uh five years just
really quick people say oh you know
you're not showing the 5 Years cuz you
know the system failed or whatever it's
not trading system it's order flow
you're reading the maret Market but
anyway um you know at this low here low
of the day
11805 nothing in the order flow it's
just your average low you got the stack
buying in Balance it's a little I'll say
off the low but cuz very at this point
you're very tight range very tight range
118 and three 11808 and 3/4 to
11805 so very tight range you do have
stacked in Balance okay I don't want to
talk about that but we did rally up get
up to the high stack uh Delta scalp for
given a sell right at the high and you
sell off again you know my charts ended
at 133 130 about more or less and bonds
really quick bonds beautiful day in the
bonds if you're using order flows and
again you know the ratios I talk about
this many many times you got ratio
bounds low with a Divergence here at 840
and what do you do you rally up to new
highs boom you're taking out the highs
you got buying and balances as you going
to the highs that's what you like to see
at your at your high of the day here
11521 you got a ratio with a Divergence
again telling you to get short and then
you sell off um unfortunately I don't
know what happened after 1:30 that's
where my charts ended but
still it doesn't get any more prettier
than this this is textbook so you know
Rally from your low on a Divergence with
the ratio up to your high with your
diver you know if you're trading just
one lot it pays for the software right
there today um again it it it doesn't uh
doesn't take much um I's talk about EUR
uh what I talk about really quick um
snps snps again you know
snps nothing special today you know just
a kind of a muted session like I said
you all the action today was in the uh
was in the NASDAQ um very tight range
most of the morning 2422 High um sorry
2422 was your low at 520 and your high
at that point was 2431 you did come in
new lows you know I I do think S&P were
sort of tracking NASDAQ today you get
down to this low Divergence no ratio you
do rally up off of that you come up um
you don't take out the high here and you
just start going down again um you know
not nothing special on the on the 10
range
[Music]
um what is this this is the Jaan
just go back a bit
here so Japanese Yen okay so just going
back to the morning time um you know you
have your high here 714 731 Delta scal
are giving you a cell right off your
high how many times have I shown you
this in other charts today you're right
off your high at your high or off your
high Delta scal are giving you a cell
that's where you want to be taking the
cells yeah you could take cells when
they're appearing near the lows but I
find you get better moves when you're
taking sell signals off highs or buy
signals off lows so here you got the
high Delta scop are giving you the sell
and you sell off um come back later make
new highs get the swing low Delta scal
are giving you a buy and what happens
and then the market just rallies again
you know you got a couple signals in the
Japanese Yan and then they're both nice
signals you I mean they're they're in
places that you want them to be um this
is
the U-turn BOS U-turn here here this one
just sort of went sideways this one was
a nice
cell and then uh my charts ended for the
day
there
and let see if there's anything else
worth
discussing yeah just really quick it's
it's not something I talk about a lot
these days is this transition indicator
um again you know this is mini do it's
tick again I'm more interested in
trading it during the day session yeah
he had one signal during the day session
and it's right here and you it was a
nice move lower um about a 30 point 30
point move down so you got one signal
one nice trade um again you can only
trade what the market gives you um you
know if the Market's not giving you any
opportunities for buys or sells then
then you know there's not going to be
anything worth trading you know I mean
you could sit there and try to read you
know people's sometimes you know one of
the reasons why people struggle with
order flow sometimes um you know just go
back to the the footprint chart real
quick is you know they they try to read
everything that's going on at once you
know concentrate on one thing you know
concentrate either on the Delta scalper
concentrate on imbalances concentrate on
ratios concentrate on
um you know stacked imbalances
concentrate on Delta you know these
things can can really um help you out a
lot you know I said you don't have to
put everything together at once you know
but build your foundation you know take
one thing that makes sense to you and go
with it and then start adding the other
pieces to the puzzle don't try to solve
you know the entire puzzle all at once
in one trade you don't have to right you
just got to wait for you know certain
types of um Market conditions to occur
right I'll give you a perfect example um
I think it was in the crude go back to
the crude here and I don't
remember now I'm just going off my
memory
um no it wasn't in the crude trying to
think what Market it was uh give me a
sec think I know I saved the chart but
just give me a
second oh the euro currency I didn't
talk about the euro currency today but
anyway um here's the euro
currency you know just really quick I'll
just show you this in the euro currency
right you're coming up to the high here
you again you know this is yeah my
software gives draws this Arrow up here
when there's you know when I think
there's trap Traders up up up near a
high or or near a low that's what this
arrow is and you know again it's
this gives you this cell okay but
there's a lot of other things going on
here yes you have a Divergence but you
know just watch it you know you're up
here at your high you got the negative
Delta strong oneus 162 the Barbie for at
121 positive Barbie for at 159 so you
sort of come up here overall in that
aggressive buying is weakening you get
up here at the high you got negative
Delta so it's telling me then the next
bar very strong negative Delta 500 so I
know that all these people that were
buying it up here you know people talk
about trap Traders but they don't really
explain it they say oh you know these
people they bought now they got to sell
yeah but how's it showing it to you
right I mean if you could read the order
flow you can see how buying is sort of
drying up here you know net Delta is is
getting weaker 159 121 then minus
negative Delta at your high strong
negative Delta in the next bar minus 500
so you know that all these people these
are weak Longs that are buying it here
you know they're buying it thinking hey
we're breaking out I want to get on
board and you know my moving average
cross this moving average I got to buy
it here that's what that's who these
people are that are coming in and buying
this high but you know sellers have
taken over sellers are slamming it in
back in their face you know even here
there there's buyers here trying to
support the market they get slammed and
then the market sells off right so again
you know that's you know that's more of
an advanced concept of order flow but
once you start putting the pieces
together you could really understand it
a bit more okay
so um you I don't know what else to say
again you know the tools that I use in
this presentation are the orderflows
trader which is the volume footprint
chart the Delta scalper which I'm
probably going to integrate into the
next version of orderflows Trader CU I
talk about Delta scalper a lot and you
know right now it's it's available you
could buy it separately
um the reason you know we sell it
separately is because you know people
that want to trade on a bar chart you
can run the Delta scalper on a normal
bar chart you don't need a an uh a
footprint chart but I was talking to my
programmer we're probably going to make
some new additions to the uh nt8 version
of order flows Trader and so we'll
probably put Delta scalper in there um
so so I mean we'll probably either phase
out Delta scalper all together so if you
don't have it you better get on board or
otherwise you got to get it through the
orderflows trader um you know it's
something I use every day in my trading
and I know people that have built
trading systems around Delta scalper um
automated trading systems around it and
I know people
that you know love it so anyway um again
you know thanks for watching this to
learn more about software I using this
presentation visit my website orderflows
docomo go to Delta scaler.com um you
could purchase it there as well so
thanks for watching this and that's all
bye-bye